i said women and children your mom
this is life or death man said women and
children
your mom
so guys we're in some new digs
for the next couple of weeks dessert um
yeah man hope you uh still fun with the
episode of course
of course um this actually with the
white wall reminds me of how it was back
in the day
yeah yeah it does [ __ ] brings us back
to our roots
oh yeah man yeah man were you day ones
that were like oh i missed you guys back
on the sofa blah blah blah here's your
opportunity
yeah yeah yeah we've got the white wall
back at the white wall back on yeah only
for a few weeks though
yeah man then we're back in our own uh
yeah
i miss it i do i'm actually not gonna
lie to you i'd say do i sometimes it was
it was very
comforting and relaxing just because of
like the aura and the energy and
where we were as opposed not necessarily
as opposed to but obviously when we go
to the stew
it's like they were there for a reason
yeah yeah yeah it was good though it was
good back in the day
it's nice but this is well this like
obviously this is nice but like i it
makes me um
realize like i like us too of course you
know i mean of course
of course when you're hopping through
hotels and you're just like i want to be
home
i want to be home i miss home yeah yeah
yeah yeah i've grown very fond of our
studio
yeah when we move i'm going to miss it
same same but
every every journey comes to an end yeah
bro so
yeah hopefully the next video will be
even better and i like that even more it
will be
but um but yeah guys of course you know
the drill
um if you guys could just real quick
like
gently brush your finger over the like
button and then if you're close to it
just click that subscribe as well yeah
um turn the notifications on yep just so
you know when we're murking about
uh typically it's on a monday but you
never know so
keep the notifications on just in case
yeah yeah yeah yeah um hit that comment
to make some friends
yeah and maybe start an argument maybe
if you're feeling if you're feeling
fruity
yeah man if you don't agree with what we
say just you know rebuttal
bless eg i'm losing my mind hey feverish
this is killing you right off
it's killing me bro i can't take it
anymore i hear you bro i've been there
jesus man like i said in the previous
episode the patron episode
um it hits me at the beginning of the
season so i'm nice now you know yeah bro
it's [ __ ] me up sorry broski
it's all good um here he goes again
bless you excuse me miner oh guys i'm so
sorry
um so speaking of patreon guys
jump on over to patreon uh the
competition is still on help us get to
that mission 1k
for the opportunity to sit down with us
and have a one-to-one hour conversation
the opportunity to have your own
individualized
personalized merchandise one of a kind
um and obviously just to get all the
bonus content that comes along with it
man of course
every patreon episode we've ever
recorded there's just there in a nice
library there's loads so jump on there
binge away i know you guys like to
binge through the episodes so jump on
that patreon been through all the
episodes
and uh we really do appreciate the
support yeah
um yeah you guys have really helped me
um
obviously personally quit my job and do
this full time
um you helped who had savings are
looking healthy for the first time in a
very long time
so guys we appreciate you so much for
the support um
and yeah man you've done great you've
changed our lives so thank you very much
we appreciate you we do appreciate it
love um i guess without further ado
it's fun fact yeah
sorry about the pause guys we'll get to
if he has fun fact in a sec
so um did you ever see that those videos
going around about the amanda got
swallowed by a whale
not long ago yeah yeah did you read up
on it yeah have you heard
no no no i read the thing and i was like
oh my god okay so
his name is michael packard he's a
professional lobster diver
who was around 45 feet below the surface
in the water off cape cod
in mesh two shits how do you [ __ ]
mass
massachusetts yeah [ __ ] yeah
that spun me i'm not gonna lie to you um
when this incident
happened the 56 year old first thought
um was that he had been attacked by a
shark but then sue realized
he didn't feel any teeth or pain he told
wbz
tv or whatever it's called all of a
sudden i felt this huge bump and
everything was dark then i realized oh
my god
i'm in a whale's mouth and he started to
swallow me and
all i thought is this is it i'm finally
gonna die finally i'm gonna die finally
you know how long have you been waiting
bro
this is it i'm finally i'm gonna die um
about 30 seconds
about after 30 seconds the well surfaced
and spat packet out and he was pulled
from the water by his crewmate and then
taken to a local hospital in
provincetown
he was released the next day having
suffered only only bruising
and mr pacquiao wrote on his fam on his
facebook post i want to thank the
provincetown rescue for taking care of
me
and help can you imagine no
can you swallowed by a whale is this
pinocchio found what's going on
everything just goes dark and you're
you're my mind
he thought he was a shark is that fine
this is it i'm gonna die finally
oh god that's the scary thing
oh jesus [ __ ] christ i would die in
there i would i would have a heart
attack before this the
thing speaks to me 100 percent as soon
as i realize i'm in a whale's mouth i
don't even know he's in a whale's mouth
i don't know but it's probably one of
the things you just know i don't know
what else could it be
yeah if i'm not yammed yet what else
could it be yeah i wonder how big you
i wonder what the spacing was like in
the whale's mouth like was it
massive in there or was he just like was
it actually like a bit snug
i don't actually i don't know because he
would have been surrounded by water
um i just realized he'd been surrounded
by water in the mouth so
who knows who knows indeed and it's spat
him out spat him up
how does he not just swallow it well
yeah but to be fair
these tiny little things so as soon as
they feel some big big body bends up in
there
yuck spat out a lucky boy that wouldn't
first of all i'm not even i'm quitting
my job that day i'm not diving in the
first you want to see me in the ocean
again that's your mistake
yeah yeah yeah that's what you get
exactly that's literally what you get
this is why we say a week in week out
leave the ocean
roll hello bro you don't know what's in
there we don't belong out there we
barely belong on here
very true we can't even deal with these
lines of tigers and bears oh my
and these men are in there swimming
getting swallowed by
whales whales no a whale leave the ocean
be brothers what a story to tell your
kids i got swallowed by a whale no one
will never believe you no one will ever
believe you
imagine if it was back a day as well
when there's no newspapers in that
afternoon no it never happened
you've never lost one shut up
literally prove it um
jesus christ that is scary man the
scariest thing i could ever think of
that is scary i'm not on stuff like that
i'm just not on stuff like that no of
course not i'd love to live of course
not
um right hold on
so i was thinking about something the
other day yeah
and you have to ask you have to promise
me to answer you have to promise me
you're going to answer me
fairly and honestly truly right yeah i
will for the show of course
okay cool so yeah okay
let's say if you're a homosexual man
right okay if you're a gay guy
okay first of all do you i mean
this is why i say you have to ask me
honestly right okay okay okay do you
do you actually think you'll be a top or
a bottom
if i was a gay guy you're a gay guy do
you think you'll be a top robot
um it's hard because
as soon as you ask me that question i
automatically said top purely because
my instinctive is i would never want to
get penetrated but i'm thinking as a
straight guy yeah you've got to think as
a gay guy bro
um i don't know bro
it's hard no pun intended
i didn't even hit that
um
i'm i i think i'm still going to stick
with my answer and say you're thinking
about talking
because you're dominating man i don't
think i can put myself mentally in a
homosexual position to
understand what it feels like to be
penetrated i just can't put myself in
that situation
because i think anything of it because
i'm not because i'm homophobic or
anything but i just physically don't
know
what it feels like yeah you have to give
up you have to be docile bro
you have to be ready to just be just
think sorry sorry it's got you off i
feel like
if i was regularly getting my ass ate as
a straight man i would be like maybe i
kind of
i've got an inkling of what something
like that may feel you know
i know what you mean so because the
waters have been tested
so maybe i might like a bit of
penetration but i don't know because my
arsenal all right
that's a baby step kind of thing all
right take the ass hole
out of it okay so i would say top or
bottom just in terms of
role okay so your role is to be the
bottom
don't worry about getting your ass
penetrated okay no one wants to get this
ass pony trained right okay okay is this
me still as homosexual
yeah okay so i'm saying in a
relationship yeah
you were a gay man yeah who's the one
that's getting his jaw
grabbed like this him
okay the question is that so you furry
believed that
you thoroughly believe that you're the
guy grips and draws i mean it depends
it's okay i'm not saying you shouldn't
said it's okay
i don't say you shouldn't believe that i
feel like
yeah i don't know because you'd have to
pay me who's pushing who against the
wall i'm pushing him
first of all all right cool but i also
don't know
pay me a picture of the guy i'm with i
don't know who you like okay that's the
thing i don't know because i
obviously don't know who you are yes do
you think it could change so do you
think you're
that's another thing so that's another
thing because some people are both as
well so it could be top bottom or both
okay so it could be dependent on how you
feel so do you feel that could be
dependent on
how you see yourself physically in the
relationship of course
you draw one guy and you're immediately
thinking
i already know i already know you know
that's why that's why it comes it
matters you know yeah
there's no way i'm trying to push man's
neck against the wall he would dash back
but he might like that it's not a fight
of course don't get me wrong but it's
not sexy
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah what you
getting around by the little little guy
yeah yeah i snapped my back
yeah yeah it doesn't fit into the facade
okay so you feel so you feel like
because this is the thing
yes you need to this is the thing as
well so obviously you know when we
we have i said we have a healthy
appreciation for an attractive guy
yes right upgrade yes so when we see a
guy and have a healthy appreciation for
an attractive guy
he's never an effeminate guy agreed he's
always
a guy's guy you know what i mean yeah
yeah agreed so
are you saying that even though
the the guys that we appreciate must get
pom or are attractive guys if you are
attracted to guys
those are the guys you wouldn't be
attracted to is that what you're saying
i think so i don't
be attracted to more feminine guys i
don't again i don't know because
if if i feel like i must be
i would be more attracted into feminine
guys purely because i think i will be
the dominant one yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah if i felt like i was the submissive
one i'll be attracted to the thoughts
yeah yeah the thoughts the thoughts of
the world
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so i feel like
it matters on mike the role all right
fair play
that makes sense that makes sense what
about you
um that was a great question by the way
oh thank you that made me think bro
i loved it that made me think so that's
not a question
i think i'll be the biggest cocktails
going
and let me tell you why you're such a
slack
be the that's cocktails going that's
hilarious hit me so
that's [ __ ] hilarious right so how
about this this is what
yeah this is how it is i think i'll be a
cox he's going because
i feel like i would attract
the duanes and the thaws of the world
okay okay so look at me
i'm light-skinned yeah i i've got a nice
physique but i'm not massive yeah yeah
yeah yeah so they look at me and think
goes after him he looks after himself
yeah it's nice yeah yeah
he got them lips as well you see what i
mean
he got that pink clips this little do
you know the little
the little bow at the top this little
this thing this little this little
shaped thing this mcdonald's m
perfect central he's got them he's got
them dick sucking lips
that's what they're thinking right dsl
yeah they're looking at me thinking he's
got them dsls
eyes are a light hazel brown okay
zoom into the eyes real quick
the eyes are a healthy chestnut so light
skinned he's got them deer cells
oh my days the eyes are a healthy glaze
of chester they will literally think of
you as a yeah yeah and i'm dragging a
wagon as well
don't enjoy the fact that i am but i've
accepted it a lot i've lived a long
enough life now why can't i set the
fight your boy's cheeked up
jokes yeah bro that's jokes i got some i
got some
i got a cape fam it's
just true bro your boy squats
i've got a cake i've grown to i've
learned to love it over the years yeah i
hear you i hear you
so that's what they're thinking so
you've got your dwayne's he's a long
you've got dwayne he's a big six
four yeah burly gentleman yeah and looks
at me
and says cheeked up dsls
roasted hazelnut eyes that's it the
trifecta yeah yeah yeah
i'm a clap some cheeks that's what he's
thinking yeah
see he draws is me i'm like swear okay
one yeah yeah good looking deep voice
all right yeah
yeah this can pattern so
man chases me back to yards yeah drapes
me back he says come back come back and
i'm like yeah yeah i had a belt
better belt is this comeback comeback
said i'm feeling that i said is it
i said this isn't it i said i'm feeling
that i said yeah
yeah i like going i
yeah and he's like yeah yeah yeah yeah
man man man tells me to get on my knees
isn't it oh my god he said i want them
dsls
yeah nah he said what
say i'm a top he says what
that says what gag the t-shirt's off now
man notices the sleeve yeah yeah is it
it's tightened up yeah
he's got some scarves so i mean
he's a bit hairier than i thought as
well he's got a bit of a better chest
is lesser a bit wider than they look
like in the
i said i'm a hoodie yeah bass
bass i'm on top g yeah grab his cheeks
and that says what i'll say get on your
tummy tub
he says nah nah i don't play that i said
shut up big man get on your tummy tum
you'll get on your tummy tum tum bro
because your boys fit in the [ __ ] son
get on that tummy tum tum because your
boy's been
fit in the [ __ ] son oh my dave man
wouldn't have a choice bro
oh my god he'd realize who's dominant in
the situation that was
throwing fam yeah he's been spoken to
like that
before he don't know how to act that's
the thing he's true you said
he's so used to not having any
confrontation on who's talking about
yeah he's in foreign soon as i flip the
script on him
wow i give him a quick jab step wow he
sees the boxing trophy's in the yard
he's thinking [ __ ] he can fight he can
move he can do it
he can mix it up yeah yeah yeah he knows
angles bro
he's got the different styles yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah found more smack him on
his back he said get on your tummy time
time bro
i'm not playing i'm not gonna tell you
again man we'll have the
the change bro oh my god so yeah i think
if i was if i was a gay man i'd be a two
star i'd be a tease bro that's funny
i'll be busting nuts
back hold tight untouched
but yeah that's that was a great
question it made me [ __ ] think
thank you it actually made me think wow
wow wow yeah um if you go would you
rather for me
gang actually do so
this is an interesting one would you
rather
be on the titanic or the twin towers
at the point of disposal
and you've got your child and you've got
an equal chance of survival in both
situations
wow what floor am i on in the twin
towers
oh so you're up up like like
like level with the plane no no no no no
you're below the plane
but you're high
if you're above your plane you're not
surviving [ __ ] yeah i know
below the plane but i'm still high or
the titanic i'd have to pick the twin
towers
uh i don't think the atlantic i don't
know what
sea it sank in but it would have been
baltic
i wouldn't have survived that sink aside
bro it would have been baltic you would
have frozen to death no wonder jack
yeah he was shaking she let jack go i
would have dashed off
the door come off the door space on the
door for us
edge up man there's space on the door
kate winslet just spread up on the door
hitch up man literally freezing did you
have your other track
um k whistler by nsg the bar is
i'll drop a man like kate winslet
wow bro leo was
generous with that with that furniture i
was saying edge up on the door now
brother now
i am freezing today i'm literally
freezing to death
literally my skin's blue move up nah
but anyway yes i will pick the twin
towers purely because of that one
obviously i don't like the c i'm not
finna freeze but the like
i don't know i would breeze down i'll
jump
staircase off the staircase after
there was people jumping out the window
isn't it no imagine
what what what possesses you to do that
you've got no choice yeah
how do you feel like you're stuck
between such a rock and a hard place
that the best chance of getting out of
here is through the
windows death or death
bro nah
wow what would you choose i actually
don't know um
what would i choose there's no way
you're picking the twin towers um
the titanic but but bear man survived
from the titanic though that's the thing
bearing amanda lifeboats and that you
hate this oh yeah i [ __ ] hate it bro
but i'm not jumping out of a window
neither am i to be fair okay what i
already know i'm not making it like
to be fair probably twin towers
why because
this is how i know there's too many
white people that worked in the twin
towers
yeah i'm not waiting for it to get to
the point where i'm jumping out the
window
as soon as i hear anything yeah yeah
down yeah yeah spider-man down the
stairs
go
i will dash whoever needs to get
dashboard i'm out of there yep
gone yep gone bro next in 30 seconds i
will be at the bottom of this
without a shadow with a doubt without a
shadow
so at least yeah i'll probably pick two
towers because even if i didn't make it
out alive i feel i would feel like i had
more control of the situation you had a
chance
of course titan you had to jump off
that's all you had because it did freeze
them like this yeah it was up there
these men had to just dive off
freezing i know i already know because
the reason why i know i'm not gonna make
a live boat is because i would wait till
the very end
i'll try and be on land as much as i can
before i get into the water really
i'm not i couldn't jump in the water bro
as soon as i heard the guy ringing the
bell
like thingy ahead i'm cranking down the
lifeboat
i'm cranking it down but you say that as
if you're next to the lifeboat
you wouldn't make a lifeboat then might
are pushing everyone out there i will
knock someone the [ __ ] out
in a life and these men think i'm an
idiot they think they still have
authority
i will smack someone across their face
bro
i said women and children your mom
this is life or death man said women and
children
your mom
let's see how many women and children
can stop me getting on this boat
let's find out
[Laughter]
let's find the [ __ ] out you can stop me
from hilarious that's hilarious i'm
getting on it man
oh i'll smack everyone out you would i
know you would that's why i've got
time for these silly little politics i'm
on the boat roll and then i'll be the
one saying women and children
as long as i'm safe yeah bro i'll get on
it as soon as i know i'm safe i'm like
guys come
quick everyone that's [ __ ] hilarious
thank you for that
what a scenario 100 i'm surviving
because i can see it now it's so funny
oh yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
i would by the way if we happen to be in
that situation together
if i'm here if i'm like folks man we
need to go and you're like i want to
stay on land as long as
you wouldn't finish the sentence before
god
you wouldn't have finished it i want to
say i will you would have lost me at
stake
i'd be like guys captain who wants to
stay go [ __ ] go i've got time for
this oh that's too funny i said i want
to stay on land as long as possible
because i just know i want to make the
lifeboat bro i just know i want to make
it
as much as i'd want to fight everyone i
just know how to make it bro they'd uh
it'll be too chaotic i'm especially
being because obviously we're talking
about it being the time that happened
right yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah back in the day was
happening like 99 or 97 i can't remember
and obviously
uh 2001 2001 [ __ ] off yeah even
earlier
um and what titanic was 19. it was
back a day before way before i was born
if i was
on the titanic i'm not a passenger
too fair do you know what i mean let's
let's really break it down
james let's really break it down you
would have been scooping coal in the
furnace i would have been
you would have been there with me my dad
i know
it would have been worse for you ah you
wouldn't look black i'm black as it is
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah you've been sorting
fam there's no way you're banging man a
man said i wouldn't have been a pastor i
wouldn't have been a passenger
you know yeah yeah yeah i wouldn't have
been there we wouldn't have to read all
right
that's for sure we would have been fam
we would have been
scooping coal
yeah we would have been the man that
when leo was
was scrolling through the stairway
pushing bodies out
it's the funniest twist that's the
funniest [ __ ] thing oh
thank you for that question they would
have laughed at us if we even broke
the topic to get a boat if as soon as we
break through that door
and we we're seen on the deck fam forget
about the iceberg what are you man doing
up there yeah
you better try and get this thing right
bam keep us afloat big man
oh we would have been the first to go oh
you think i'm a passenger you're
laughing
you're laughing brother he wouldn't have
made the ball
oh my god that's so funny bro
that's so funny a man said we both know
i wouldn't have been a passenger
oh facts oh there's no way so there's no
way in hell brother oh we would have
been the help
[Music]
there's no way we're squeezing up a boat
oh never
say women children [ __ ]
bar staff and just say the captain stays
with his ship
he would have stayed on the ship while
sitting on our back
and this is the captain goes down with
his ship the captain and the blacks
they go down with the ship it was the
captains the blacks and the violence
oh the violinist oh all that man's
saying what are you thinking
nah you no we're invited on
yeah and you chose to stay yeah you're
dumb that's your problem yeah yeah yeah
you have a choice yeah yeah yeah we were
busy scooping no
choice no choice that is dread
bro lucky now oh that's funny okay
question
do you i've got a trash news or do you
want to do a a mighty [ __ ]
slash um would you not would you rather
what's it called
am i the only fan request fan request
um i think i'd like to squeeze both if
that's all right
okay try okay i'll do my i'll do my
trash now trust news i mean because you
said trash news
i want to know because the fans love
them by the [ __ ] so we have to do
money ourselves we've not done this in a
while so i'll
breeze through it yeah
world's most identical twins plan to get
pregnant
at the same time after getting engaged
to the same man
why do i feel i think i've seen these
man on a show or something
they finish each other's sentences and
[ __ ] i have no idea i've not
delved into their lives but i've just
got the script how can you get pregnant
at the same time by the same man
well just on the same day yeah i'm
assuming they're just [ __ ] the same
day they're probably on the same cycle
mad probably mad
he's the luckiest guy but also not
is he he's really actually not i'm just
saying in that one
scenario in that one scenario
where both of them are just said leave
it in both of them just leave it in
do you think before i even actually get
to this trash news because i'm i'm i've
got questions in my head now do you
think
one he forgets who's who because i would
i'm looking at them and i couldn't tell
them apart yeah yeah
two they'll be right here by the way um
two that do you think he met one
they decided to have fun with him
flipped he didn't notice
and then he just kind of patted oh
imagine that kind of played out
or maybe i reckon i reckon if they're
the
world's most identical twins and if
they're the kind of if they're the same
twins that i think i've seen on a tv
show one time
i guarantee they both move to him at the
same time
i guarantee that they both decided that
they fancy him and both moved in like
it's like
it's normal my heart will leave my chest
both of them just like hi what's your
name i'll be like what's going on
fam oh my days bro
anyway before we diverge into that let
me actually read the thing
all right two australian identical twins
will be getting married to the same man
after he proposed to them on a u.s
reality tv show so it might be there
yeah yeah perth sisters anna and lucy
desync 35 have they
have been dating a 37 year old
electrician been buyer for 10
years now ah jesus in the most recent
episode of the tlc's extreme sisters
yep thanks fun you know your stuff in
the most
in the most recent episode of tlc's
extreme sisters ben took the girls on a
romantic park picnic where
to the shot and tap to the shock and
happiness he finally popped the question
they have been longing to hear after he
proposed he handed each sister a small
box
that featured a huge diamond ring he
then put the band on the women's rings
fingers one at a time
the large engagement rings had three
bands with ben had
with which ben had symbolized the three
of them
um anna you mean this is what he said on
the thing i know you mean the world to
me and i want to spend the rest of my
life with you
and lucy you mean the world to me and i
want to spend the rest of my life with
you
i love you and i love you both ben told
the sisters
as the australian doesn't allow as
australia so he doesn't allow three
people to get married
they truly are looking to looking at
other options in malaysia indonesia
or other parts of america um where
they'll be able to i'm willing to do
whatever it takes to make the girls
happy
dang they are planning to start a family
with the sisters hoping to fall pregnant
at the same time through ivf that's how
he does
okay something they have been told one
they've also wanted to do for years
and i said if she felt pregnant her
sister would definitely get pregnant
straight away because their bodies need
their bodies our bodies need to be the
same we need to try and make this happen
definitely can you i'd love to know what
the kids that come out look like
bro it'll be weird
imagine they both give birth to twins
that'll be insane that that will mess
with my head bro that would be insane i
messed with my absolute head
um yeah to be fair my um
so my stepmom's sister like my step-aunt
um she has twin girls
yeah and her um their dad
has um
another set of twins with another woman
so he has he has
a set of twin boys and a set of twin
girls oh my god
how wild is that mad why the odds what
are the odds what are the
odds of that oh i'd look down on my toe
like again
again luckily he's got pre
thankful luckily he's got pee oh come on
but yeah bro
oh two sets of twins again bro long
long how how far apart are they oh a
good
uh a good few years okay a good feeling
yeah
about the two different moms bruv
you think he's just busting ah [ __ ] that
no no no no no no
cool yeah what was the thing you got for
me
oh two seconds let me find it hi guys
absolutely love your show i need your
opinions i don't know what's going on
so i've been doing bits with a guy just
sex nothing serious he's been to mine
three times
one we have never kissed two when
[ __ ] has always been from behind
and he always says not no to going on
top
but it's all talk but is all talk over
text
he has a rather small sausage so it
don't really stay in at all which kind
of makes it always but it doesn't bother
me because it's still
fun oh dude [ __ ]
speak three when having conversation in
person it doesn't make eye contact
at all we met through a mutual friend
for the first
we met through his mutual friend the
first time he was very very chatty
now when i hang out with them it's like
i'm invisible and he doesn't talk to me
or make eye contact
no one knows we do business together he
made the first suggestions about [ __ ]
and he's obsessed with my ass
shock
he lives an hour away from me our mutual
friend lives in the middle of us he
comes out of his way to see me and if he
can he will stay at mine
i don't understand why he won't make eye
contact with me and i assume this is why
he won't go on top jesus that's jokes
wow that's peak as well it is the other
day
he said when we he the other day he said
when we get in together
i thought this meant hook up but he said
no more
more than just sex we don't talk much on
text and he's not
mentioned anything about this in the
past and in the past he also said i
rate you i am confused guys and that was
it
so to summarize bro is her thing locked
oh because you saw you heard fat ass
yeah i'm trying to see what these cheeks
are all about
i thought he's obsessed obsessed with
his ass jesus
but yeah okay quick rapidly rap
sorry um actually no do you do you recap
and
then i'll say so recap um seeing a guy
just sex they've never kissed when
[ __ ]
um only from behind never goes on top
because he doesn't want to make eye
contact
and he's got a small dick and when they
first met
they met through a mutual friend they
were very chatty but now
they don't make eye contact anymore and
he lives an hour away from her
but he always makes the effort to go
over and he wants to stay over sometimes
and now he's saying ah when are we gonna
do more than sex when are we actually
getting together whereas he
doesn't make conversation at all when
the minute when they're face to face
that when are we getting together it's
thrown me you know that's throwing me as
well because i was about to say big man
he just wants them cheeks he does he
don't want to look at you bro
he just wants to [ __ ] clap those cheeks
and dip
i'm also thinking whether he's just
thinking
as an immature person and saying let me
be with her just so i can keep clapping
her
you know that did cross my mind some
guys some guys do that
because we we're thinking as us yeah
and sometimes like we've had this before
where someone
um someone sent a fan request or am i
the also saying
he [ __ ] her he liked he loved the sexy
we went out with her
and it was just a bang something along
those lines because he just wanted to
bang oh
the guy he sent it in yeah the guy sent
it in yeah i said i've really wanted to
be a [ __ ] this girl for ages and then
like my wife done now
um but something like she's still not
freaking out or something that's nothing
exactly he was a dog not the good kind
either
he was just a dick yeah so you know what
i'm saying so i'm thinking
he could be trying to navigate that
direction but again
that's a weak way to think but if it's
the direction we think
he's just a confused he doesn't know
what he wants clearly so you need to get
yourself out of situation it's easy
because
one you said it's just sex two if he's
tall isn't that big and it's not really
doing that much for you then obviously
another easy out for you three
your friends don't even know so it's not
even awkward with anyone yeah so you can
done the dance and just move on you know
yeah yeah yeah
you can just move on the only awkward
thing is like if he's actually being
genuine like he wants more than
he's clearly not he doesn't know how to
communicate
yeah he doesn't know that's good and
there's no eye contacting only smell it
slamming you from behind
clearly he loves your ass because he
loves to [ __ ] you doggy but
not wanting to make eye contact i'll go
on top and then say oh
want to be getting together yeah what is
it is he on the spectrum or something
that's what i want to know is he on the
brand he's giving off mad spectrum
advice bad signals
mad signals yeah bro like
when are we going to be boyfriend and
girlfriend yes awesome
big man you don't look at me you won't
look at me
you flip me over everything tap me from
the back and then dip
you don't look at me you don't even talk
when we're in the group
where amongst friends you don't even
speak to me don't even make conversation
barely talk to me over text and now you
want to
wife me up no bro is it me or the cheeks
bro
just tell me just just tell just be
honest and be out with it man i just
want to know if it's just the arse that
you want then i'm happy to free up time
and time again
cause like i said it's fun yeah it's fun
for me but bro i just want to know what
it is
if that's the case of him just trying to
wife it just to smash mandom just need
to be honest
because more time the girl is down for
that she's been down for it
you don't need to make excuses
i don't he's probably thinking yo
eventually she's gonna stop
just [ __ ] with me because i don't
even look at her yeah she
i need to offer more yep yep yeah but at
the same time i still don't want to look
at her
oh my days easy man look he's i get it
now
i really want to see what else looks
like because he's obsessed with the ass
run the picture that you teach you just
do the contest you know who you are just
for research
you are yeah yeah send us a still
an emotion picture yeah just so we can
see the balance yeah so yeah so we can
see like oh
okay yeah we get it now like it is
actually just a jigs or we could be like
what actually no like i can see why he
likes it but
i don't think it is because sometimes
it sounds like if your ass is fat fat it
could be a fetish thing
if you've just got a bagging ass then
maybe he's on the spectrum i don't know
maybe it's just a bad guy i don't know
but like that's not even funny
i i don't have if your ass is like
ridiculous yeah he just might have a
face he might just have a face just
he doesn't like you like you're right
yeah he doesn't see you as an actual
person
he sees you as just me plastic meaty
cheeks
yeah for the fact you called it a
sausage i already know it's dead
sausage cocktail thing
so um i would say okay cool so dilemma i
would say
he's clearly not being open enough yeah
so you need to say
i would just say black on white listen
bro listen
i'm fine with how things are but a few
things
you genuinely don't even make eye
contact with me
and that's the concern yeah i'm gonna be
honest with you bro
that's a concern yeah yeah frank's right
you can't just keep [ __ ] coming here
smashing me from the back and that just
be the end of it and then you want to be
my partner oh god no what's this
relationship going to look like
yeah because if it's just more of this
and i'm all right i'm done it's
embarrassing clearly it's great for you
yeah trust me it's just
right for me it's terrible for me yeah
it's it's literally like your tool is
not even all done
even caught in it imagine someone
telling you that it wasn't there
oh imagine yet imagine crushing
imagine there could be someone that's
like
sending in a message about you bro
saying that i actually do like this guy
but his tall is just basic
i've never thought that imagine that's
imagine you're on the bottom end of a
fan request to someone else's pod
kevin samuels oh my days
imagine [ __ ]
[ __ ] speaking of kevin avenues have you
ever wanted to just see what it say
about you
i don't even know who that is james
that's the guy that um black guy with
the glasses
who destroys people bro i think that's a
high value man kind of guy
as soon as you said glasses is it
comedian no he's a black guy guys
he sits he does like a show and he does
lives with people oh no then
there's a woman like oh i make this much
kevin simon he's
very sure it's kevin samuels but yeah
sorry soon as soon as you see you'll
know exactly who it is
i feel like he's is he on the show as
well or not well he's on youtube i see
he's
all over tik tok bro that clips of his
his [ __ ] is all over tik tok
is he not the one that's starting like a
entrepreneurship team is he english or
american american okay then
no no no so basically the premise of his
[ __ ] is like
it's like relationship advice kind of
thing okay and it's basically a lot of
it
is him bringing women and men but mostly
women
back down to earth who think there's
women on there that basically say look
i want a man who can provide this i want
a man who can provide that
i'm sick and tired of getting approached
by these guys who are below me et cetera
et cetera
and people like cool say less um how
much do you weigh
and they'll be like oh wait this much
how much do you make a year i'll make
this much have you got kids
yes um are you divorced yes cool how old
are you yes
um like i'm this age oh cool cool cool
cool right and he's like
and then he'll get all the information
like cool big mountain you're telling me
that you're 45 divorced 180 pounds
five foot four bro two kids
you make 40 grand a year in dollars so
like
20 something in pounds and you deserve a
man who's
playing professional basketball you're
out of your [ __ ] mind
you don't deserve that you deserve the
plumbers that have been approaching you
bro that's exactly what you deserve
the plumbers bro these electricians
these tradesmen wow
these bus drivers that are trying to
bank wow free it up
trust me because that's all you deserve
that's all you're getting
he will say get your [ __ ] together and
stop being so entitled you don't deserve
[ __ ] bro you bring nothing to the table
you bring
nothing he does he does this constantly
bro
wow constantly how did they react
there a lot of them are just like wow
wow wow some of them cry
a lot of them get defensive oh yeah for
sure no no well there's something
sharp sharp sharp and when he's had
enough of me just cuts the thing off
cuts the thing off um yeah yeah yeah
yeah he's on youtube that's jokes
there's one woman on the other day that
she was trying to come sexy with it
sexy with it bro it was hilarious she
she come and um she come on and she was
like hi
and he was like oh hi and then um she
goes um trying to put this sexy
voiceover i don't know what you're
talking about tonight
but i just want to let you know and he
cuts off like how old are you and then
she goes why don't you take a guess
man locked off the thing am i saying
don't play games with me
just carried onto what he was doing on
his computer fam it's the funniest thing
i've ever seen
it's the funniest thing i've ever seen
i'll try and let me try and bring up
just a very quick
try to do a power play well she tried to
roll reverse the whole thing
she's trying to do the whole thing she's
trying to think right kevin's
he doesn't play games bro that's funny
he doesn't play i'm surprised you've
never sent me any of any other man takes
off
i thought i had man never that's
hilarious
right let's see what he's got okay cool
so like i want a high value man and
that's what i'm looking for
as a female i feel you know i'm building
myself for that type of man
but the type of men that i meet um why
do you want a high value man
because who i feel um
i deserve that you don't deserve
anything
oh okay who are you
um simone chimon deserves nothing
no one in this world is excuse me
what makes you so special do you deserve
access to somebody else's stuff
um nothing really makes me special to
deserve access to anybody's thing but my
own
thank you so you don't deserve a high
value man you don't deserve
nobody deserves anything we earn yeah
bro
it's video after video after video
okay bro he don't play that [ __ ] he
literally doesn't play that [ __ ]
i've not heard one clip of him being
like to be fair you do deserve a high
value man
fair enough okay to be very interesting
that's
that's good to watch as male or female
you know oh he's done it to guys as well
bro
it stirs up anything that's still man
went on there one time oh i'm tired of
this i'm tired of
like i can't pull any girls man said oh
how like he said how big are you
whatever and the guy was like i'm a bit
overweight
he's like you got a big dick i was like
what he's like
have you got a big dick he's like oh
it's kind of average he's like
then you don't deserve [ __ ] bro you
can't get [ __ ] because you've got a
small dick
and if you're a bit of a fat you're fat
with a small dick you're coming crying
to me about why can't i get [ __ ] oh
i did get your [ __ ] together give your
[ __ ] [ __ ] together [ __ ] it's just
bold
clean advice he looks like he got to 45
and just said enough
he's enough tired of this
[ __ ] tired of this [ __ ] [ __ ] man all
the time bro that's
that's we're going to be kevin samuels
in in
like five to ten years yes when i get a
little bit more salt and pepper yes i'm
just gonna have my glasses on
and then be like james am i the [ __ ]
yes
why xyz yeah bang bang get off
i haven't got time for this anymore i'm
not doing this dance anymore oh you man
um what were we talking about no idea
james i'm not gonna lie to you no idea
what were we talking about
uh city sausage get yourself a high
value man man
he's a waste of space he is don't even
entertain us when we're getting together
yeah yeah yeah just don't even entertain
it yeah just why are we why we haven't
even this conversation there's no dance
that needs to be danced them bro
you've just told us you've got a man
that's only obsessed with your ass won't
look you in the eyes
he's got a [ __ ] basic piece you have
a little bit of fun
he won't even talk to you over text and
now he's trying to pursue a relationship
with you
and you're in a dilemma he's giving you
seven outs
bro you're surrounded by red flags
surrounded
and you're good where's the dilemma
surrounded you should have been
gone from the job if you want to keep
getting banged from the back then just
tell him bro you can [ __ ] me but i don't
want anything else to do with you cause
you're pretty much useless
in any other area and you're barely
competent in this one
i haven't busted a nut in ages this is a
bit of fun for me
an emphasis on the bit do you know
what's crazy i think
well i don't know but i think maybe the
the complex of being idolized
could be the reason why she's banging
him not necessarily idolized but like
you said
like she said rather he's obsessed with
her art and she likes that she likes
that yeah she gets a kick out i mean
yeah
maybe that's that might play a part why
she thinks she's in a dilemma
yeah do you break my throat bottle on
the floor please that empty ass ball
this is why she might think she's in a
dilemma maybe because she
not necessarily might enjoy the sex but
because she he always wants to fight he
worships those cheeks boy you know
that's what must be a weird feeling it
must be yeah imagine the girl was just
like
i need your toe in my mouth now i
need it bro i'm obsessed with it i can't
get enough of it
it's like sugar to me it's cocaine give
me it i need it
i don't want anything else don't even
talk to me i don't want to look at you i
just want that tall
now that's sexy to me for
of course that might be a dilemma yeah
and then that same goal says i want you
to be your girlfriend yeah
you'll be like hey i mean i want to be
loved
she basically i just want that tool
forever and i'll put up with whatever
comes with it
my days yeah knock him off please yeah
please for the love of god for your sake
in our secret send us the vids though in
the pic
oh yeah let's see the cheeks so we can
well and truly um figure this out yeah
we're intrigued yeah
for research um but guys we'll see you
next week signing off see you next week
catch a bit peace